-♪ Google Translate Songs ♪
-Now, if you've ever
used Google Translate,
uh, you know that
it's not always perfect.
For example, when translated
to Croatian and back,
"The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon"
becomes "The Evening Show
That Plays Jimmy Fallon."
[ Laughter ]
So, we did the same thing
with popular song lyrics.
Some people have done
this online. It's super-fun.
So, we're gonna try this
right now.
Miley, you are the star
of the show tonight,
so you are up first.
-Here we go.
-You will be singing
the Google Translate version
of "Shape of You,"
by Ed Sheeran.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Translated, it is called,
"Your Body's Curves."
[ Laughter ]
Roots?
-Here we go.
-One, two, three.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
-♪ Your child demands silence ♪
♪ Latch to my torso
and throw me a cadaver ♪
♪ Please chase after my boss ♪
♪ Please, please chase
after my boss ♪
♪ Uh ♪
♪ I stand on
your body's curves ♪
♪ We do not like pressure
stones make ♪
♪ But my organ drops right out ♪
♪ Yeah, I like that cadaver ♪
♪ Previously you came
to my abode ♪
♪ The bed papers,
they stink like you ♪
♪ There have become
daily insights ♪
♪ Yeah, I like cadaver ♪
-♪ Ooh, ah, ooh, ah,
ooh, ah, ooh, ah ♪
-♪ Oh, I like that cadaver ♪
-♪ Ooh, ah, ooh, ah,
ooh, ah, ooh, ah ♪
-♪ Oh, I like that cadaver ♪
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-♪ We do not like pressure
stones make ♪
-Pressure stones make?
What was it?
-♪ We do not like pressure
stones make ♪
-Uh, all right.
It's my turn.
I will be performing
the Google Translated version of
the Rick James' classic
"Super Freak"...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...which is now called
"Really Weird."
[ Laughter ]
Here we go.
-One, two.
♪♪
-♪ This girl has an exemplary ♪
♪ Until toenails
come from the top ♪
♪ Behind the scenes is patience
with his time in Hawaii ♪
♪ Oh, girl ♪
♪ This girl is my relative ♪
-♪ The girl has become mad ♪
-♪ Literacy for the girl ♪
-♪ Newspaper's new thoughts ♪
-♪ She is okay, she is okay ♪
♪ The girl has become okay
for me ♪
♪ She's really weird,
really weird ♪
♪ She's really weird, yes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Miley...
you're up again.
This time, you'll be singing
Dusty Springfield's
"Son of a Preacher Man."
-All right.
-It is now called
"A Minister's Male Child."
[ Laughter ]
Roots.
-One, two, three.
♪♪
-♪ Not so good
is becoming heavy ♪
♪ I will not have action ♪
♪ His conversation
was pretty tasty ♪
♪ He arrived to say
that he was correct ♪
♪ He married me and said
♪ Can you tell me
where I left my house? ♪
♪ Yeah, the only person
who ever contacted me ♪
♪ A minister's male child ♪
♪ And the only one male child
ever informed me ♪
♪ A minister's male child ♪
♪ Yes, he is, he, oh, yes,
he is, oh, oh, yes, is he ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He is oh.
-Yes, he is. Oh, yes is he.
-Can you tell me
where I left my house?
-[ Laughs ]
That's my favorite one.
Uh...
-We do not like pressure
stones make.
-Oh, I know.
We do not like pressure
stones make.
Uh, for this last one,
let's do a duet.
Is that cool?
-Oh, dream come true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh, this is "Ain't No Mountain
High Enough"...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...by Marvin Gaye
and Tammi Terrell.
But we'll be singing
the translated version,
which is called "Landforms
Don't Prefer to Get High."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here we go.
-Roots.
-One, two, three, four.
♪♪
-♪ My love can breathe ♪
♪ Direction heart deep ♪
♪ Separated kilometers ♪
-♪ I want aided limbs ♪
♪ I arrive two times ♪
♪ Very rapidly ♪
-♪ I'm aware that ♪
♪ Landforms don't prefer
to get high ♪
♪ Depressions don't prefer
to fall over ♪
♪ I won't overweight
your harbor ♪
♪ I'm gonna purchase
your baby ♪
-Oh! Miley Cyrus is performing
her hit song "Malibu"
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.
Miley Cyrus.
-♪ I'm aware that ♪
♪ Landforms don't prefer
to get high ♪
♪ Depressions don't prefer
to fall over ♪
♪ I won't overweight
your harbor ♪
♪ I'm gonna purchase
your baby ♪